what would any of you guys like to hear
a rap about cockney rhymes
cockney rhymes do you have a particular
favorite cockney rhyme
uh pearson stairs pears and stairs
you're very drunk aren't you sir
pears and stairs yes so then the cottony
ramen slang would
would be apples and pears which
translates our stairs so
rather than saying stairs you would say
apples and pears which is three
syllables longer than saying the word
stairs
the cockney's very strange people but
there you go um
cockney around slang focusing on apples
and pears if you are
in um this kind of triangle here what do
you wanna wrap about
little mermaid the little mermaid who
said that
hello there are you a fan of the
animation yeah yeah what's your favorite
part of that film
um when ariel thinks about make a part
of that world
when ariel sings about being part of
that world cool so the yeah
the song is is it part of that world a
part of your world what's the correct
title
well i'm so sorry daughter of walt
disney just like
do not besmirch my dad's legacy
so when yeah ariel little mermaid and
part of that world
cutting ramps like apples of pears
middle of the room in this area what do
you want to rap about
25th birthday feels very egotistical and
self-aggrandizing
but may i ask whoever's birthday it was
what what to watch was one of the gifts
you received
oh it's coming up well no then no that's
uh
lemon lemon cake okay well if
technically food but lemon cake on your
25th birthday
is a perfectly fine suggestion um let's
come to people over
here what do we rap about one second one
second i'll come to you in a second
you're not in that segment but you you
came with that pre-prepared right
okay so there were several things i
heard birth control what was that
what one second that person was saying a
very long phrase there yeah the
louisiana purchase did you say
okay
uh yeah someone said birth control as
well and you said croatian bathing suit
but that man was very adamant that
louisiana purchased was what was going
to be suggested
and who am i to deny him now uh
you said something down here what was it
a parrot with an existential crisis cool
i like it it's a bit too overwrought to
be truly funny but it's good
i i will never fail to be amazed and
surprised
how supportive you are when someone just
gets hot so
this then lovely people of the comedy
seller is is what we call a freestyle
rap that's a wrap made up on the spot
based on talion suggestions the
suggestions to remind you are
the louisiana purchase apparently an
existential crisis
this is lovely uh little mermaid part of
the world cotton or amazon apples and
pears
lemon drizzle cake on lemon cake on your
25th birthday and do not worry it will
not be anywhere near as atrociously
embarrassingly tokenly
as you're expecting a proudly educated
middle class white boy to be although
it may be if this beat doesn't work
properly because it's not plugged in
so let me do this and we'll see if we
can get it to go that sounds like it's
about to
work okay well imagine how good this
would have been if i'd done a sound
check but there we go
here we go that's what i'm talking about
[Music]
starting with applause that's a very
pleasant din i'll be sitting on the
shore you can look at all my fins i'm a
mermaid i'll share with y'all no vagina
but the boobs name
ariel she's like 14. that's the daughter
of poseidon maybe in disney they call it
king pride and
a little friend that's a sidekick a
crowd called sebastian yes i
pick but one of the developers there in
the lab
was like on what accent for the crap
surely it should be
erudite i'm mistaken now let me go
caribbean made jamaican
oh ariela hair unfurled got a four cause
i can't want to be part of that world
that one there on the shore in the head
melody spewing out and she wants those
legs but the fairy tale that it's based
on if she's on the sand seeing eric and
she's chasing
every single time she steps a little
inch it feels like knives
inner thighs pinching they don't even
put that in it's not
part of the fairy tale if you ain't got
legs then you're gonna fail
to try and get upstairs from below it's
why
she must live in a bungalow and if
you're there
you can't stare at those stairs the
cockney's all right they're like apples
have you got the bread bro translate the
bread you know it means
all the money i know it's funny that we
got the sheen on the side with the
currency the face of the queen
they call up elizabeth army old china
other little words but i'm feeling from
a shyness what like i've got a little
beak i can't speak when i visit my
psychiatrist
in the middle of the week i say ah who's
a pretty boy who's a pretty boy and the
therapist looks at me annoyed he's like
wow
you're eager typical and narcissistic
obviously going through exists essential
crisis
whoa i slipped up on the words on the
syllable it's fine
see a little parrot all this feathers
beautiful saying are you okay are you
feeling good do you want a little
cracker the parrot's been understood
he's like yes i love it with the cracker
that i've got i wish i had a little
shoulder sitting on with a pirate
i could be on a ship on the seven seas
maybe have some croatians in the water
with me
wearing bathing suits yeah i know bro
i'd have sex with them because i'm on
birth control
and that's fine you know that i deserve
this i serve it up like louisiana
purchase
i only know this vaguely it was brought
from the french
king louis he sold it off to the yankees
they were like what a great deal rub
their hands with glee of course please
they want to get the land and basically
it's just floods we all understand
when it comes to louisiana always
feeling pain why because the federal
government
ignores the hurricane and that's such a
real sad thing
we can't take in wow that's a bad
mistake but let me cheer everybody up i
go and i take
i say hi guys here's some lemon cake
they're like no
we need funding from fema when it comes
to birthdays
no one was keener than you it's not now
it's not yesterday but it's coming soon
one day be on its way you'll be
there like oh i got my birthday wishes
they got me all the flour sugar mixed it
with the citrus
put in all the egg cook it in the oven
that's the lemon birthday cake that's
the thing that you're loving